this morning we're sharing more of our
exclusive conversation with r kelly's
survivor asriel clary when we first
spoke with her in 2019 she was just 21
years old and had lived with r kelly for
almost five years
later on she told us she realized her
relationship was abusive she testified
against kelly during his federal
racketeering and sex trafficking trial
here in new york he was found guilty on
all charges and now faces life in prison
a cbs news special love doesn't hurt our
kelly survivor speaks has more of our
recent conversation love doesn't hurt is
the phrase she used with us it comes out
today on our viacom streaming platform
paramount plus here is asriel clary
talking about leaving r kelly
if you are leaving something
traumatizing more than you want to
breathe you need support you need
foundation that feels loved and that
that loves you
and so i'm very happy that i had that
what do you think anybody could have
said or done
to help you leave the situation sooner
nothing nothing nothing
i feel like that is something that i
would have had to have woken up from
myself something that i would have had
to realize on myself
and you know a lot of people don't
realize with victims the more you try to
help them the more it upsets them
sometimes you know because this is all
they know this is the only person that
they
have have been comfortable around so you
know the more you try to
separate that the more they only run to
what they know
r kelly's high profile trial brought new
attention to domestic violence in this
country on average nearly one in three
women experience domestic violence
that's a very high number and that's
according to the national domestic
violence hotline tama bryant is a
clinical psychologist she's also the
director of the culture and trauma
research laboratory at pepperdine
university good morning to you miss
brian it's really good to have you here
team o'brien good morning thank you i'm
so glad
i'm so glad you're here i was on a plane
this weekend and three different people
stopped me and said you know she could
have left if she wanted to he wasn't
physically holding her she was there for
her career she enjoyed being with him
and it's so hard to try to explain to
people who haven't been in this
situation what do you say to people many
people feel this way and first let me
say this is why it's so important you're
doing this segment because of the victim
blaming that is so pervasive in society
people say why didn't you say anything
yeah and then when people speak up they
find reasons about why you did it wrong
and why you should have done it
differently so there are many reasons
that make it hard to leave and one of
the languages sometimes that we use is
why didn't you escape if you ask if you
use the word escape instead of just
leave you realize how big you're asking
someone to push back on someone who has
been really controlling their mind so
one of the big factors is fear and we
know that you increase the risk for
death when you try to leave that abusers
are more likely to try to actually take
your life or increase the violence when
you are trying to escape and there is a
greater chance of homicide not only is
there the fear of death but the fear of
can i make it on my own that this person
has undermined your self-esteem and so
you really feel uncertain and many
people have turned away from you over
the years people tried to help you they
gave up on you so then it's i'm going to
leave this person and go where another
big factor that makes it hard to escape
is love and what is the message we
always tell people is nobody's perfect
relationships aren't easy you have to
stick to it these days people walk away
too soon so there is this double message
that if you love someone you're going to
be right or die you're going to stay
with them no matter what you're going to
help them through it and the love
actually also keeps hope alive right
because with the cycle of violence
usually people are not terrible every
day all day and so each time someone has
that honeymoon phase or they're being
kinder you believe they're changing
things are going to be better this time
and then i just say there's also the
cultural and religious pressures a lot
of people will say
if they are married i made a covenant
with god right and i promise let's do
his prayers for better or for worse so
culturally religiously we have to start
sending a different message that fear is
not love so
go ahead
go ahead well i want to talk about the
signs of domestic abuse because when
people are hopeful or they're in love
they may not realize that what they're
experiencing is not normal and not okay
because in the context of their
experience it feels like it is yes and
she said it was normalized too yeah to
your point so what is the line where
it's it's not just
relationships are hard but it's abuse
yes so we want to pay attention to
physical violence sexual violence and
psychological violence usually the
physical and sexual people will notice
but i'll say even the physical at first
people can minimize like they'll say it
wasn't a punch it was a push or it was a
grab or they restrained me or it was an
open hand or i shouldn't have said it
right or i shouldn't have said that to
you yes so the blaming uh because
sometimes even the abuser will say i
wish you had made me do that right i
didn't want to do that so any form of uh
physical violence is abuse sexual
violence and we don't talk about this
within relationships actually within
this nation initially sexual assault
within marriage was not a crime so we
had to really make the case that you
still have ownership of your body
because people say well you're with them
so then you agree to it but the big
piece is also the psychological yes uh
it is the verbal it's the manipulation
emotional yes the
and it undermines your self-worth and
your self-value so then you have the
public on top of that saying you're
stupid you're you know out for money and
so it can really crush you
and i'm sorry we're gonna have to leave
it there you gave us some dr brian this
is very clarifying thank you thank you
thank you for having me you can watch
the cbs news special love doesn't hurt
our kelly survivor speaks it's tonight
on paramount plus